it was always very unpleasant it was
always very very difficult to hold
things together but this really could
have gone either way
what a game by Fabby what a defensive
effort by abbasov but it won't quite be
enough
I also I have Admiral admiration for
fabi's decision the courage that he was
taking this C3 pawn and there is the
handshake big congratulations to Fabi
bouncing back on demand fantastic stuff
that's we love to see and we're gonna
have two incredible tie breaks tomorrow
and we will be spoiled tomorrow spoiled
of course by Carlson Prague our
championship match but also by this
match where Ninjago will have to put the
painful memory of this game behind him
and try to complete his Cinderella run
in the rapid portion of this match the
score in both of our matches is official
uh the classical portion has concluded
and it is 1-1